like I don't know this is real this is
bad man hey what's going on everybody
four first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones the show with
hot questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Hasan Minhaj you
know I'm from The Daily Show and he's
making this theatrical debut with
homecoming king this fall Hasan welcome
to the show
thanks for having me man how are you
with hot food as an Indian I'm pretty
good do you feel pressure like yeah
pressure of your people like on your
shoulders and you really need to come
correct like when I watch it I'm a fan
of the show up in front of everybody you
interview but also like the Indian in me
is like like RIT like sriracha like
really like Oh top it to you like really
like when I saw Khalid drop out after 3
I was like come on oh yeah
that's a story unto itself are you ready
to get it started get into it
all right so sriracha is no big deal
this is these are layup lines yeah I
mean right-handed layups let's do a
left-hand layup
all right so you and I have both worked
with DJ Khaled as you just said he oh my
god you did the sneaker closet parody on
Comedy Central basically parody what you
guys essentially did exactly I was
awesome and you dope into Callens world
matter of fact congratulations you
didn't play yourself thank you but it
was funny because khaled has kind of
almost become a list at this point yeah
but back when he was with us he wasn't
quite at that like Ellen DeGeneres level
no no I saw him and I was like this is a
Malcolm Gladwell tipping point situation
right he has gotten his 10,000 hours of
cloth talk in yes and it's about to like
really blow up in a major way and then
you know what - it's been funny to see
his evolution as a celebrity he's on
Ellen DeGeneres they're like who are
they and when he was on my show I asked
him that question six months before
anybody asked him that question yeah I
asked him that he's like they are the
[ __ ] that was boy [ __ ] boy that's one of
the best that's one of the best sound
bites ever I mean this is a better word
for hater mad people bums
losers garbage I got piece of [ __ ] how
did he greet you when you got to his
place what's up man is gonna be the
biggest interview of your whole career
and dare I say it's up there it might
have been it might have been my pit
Khaled prime minister justin trudeau yep
brock obama and you mend that order
there's like an Air Jordan three white
cement classic classic you're wearing
those right now right now man come on
man come on oh shut up on eye shadow sir
Viacom these Correspondents Dinner
events always seem like oil finition of
an oil crowd because you have these
criminy reporters you have these robotic
politicians yeah you have people that
are trying to awkwardly laugh at brown
people jokes and it's always weird
correctable right what's crazy is is
that event the Congressional
Correspondents Dinner was three days
after Orlando so what was happening in
the zeitgeist was like gun control
all of this stuff was in the zeitgeist
and specifically in regards to Congress
there was like massive congressional
inaction it's interesting that you say
this because when you watch your speech
in about the 18 minute mark you can see
that it's all jokes
up until the 18 minute mark yeah and
then you can see that clearly
philosophically you made a decision yeah
go from comedy to something with more
weight and I wondered why I'm the only
one of Adam all my like I consider like
comedians like we're like this tribe had
the whole tribe that got this chance to
say it to their face
one shot mom spaghetti eight-mile like
say it right and I would be remiss if I
didn't take that shot ultimately what I
wanted to let them know was like hey
look we turn to you God you guys are
like you guys are thought leaders you
guys are leaders in society we don't pay
you to write tweets and send us your
hashtags and thoughts and prayers we pay
you guys and turn to you guys and vote
for you guys to pass legislation so do
that
this looks a lot redder than the other
ones but it's not that tough of sauce
plus you did come in here talking a big
game and sound that's talking a lot of
[ __ ] you were you met Michael Jordan
what was that like because everybody has
Michael Jordan horror stories and
they're my favorite genre of story I
love him I can't get enough of him I met
Michael Jordan but I didn't meet him I
tried to meet him and then I got body
slammed by his bodyguard
since soon as they happen I didn't fully
understand context there's this brown
kid running from across the casino floor
yelling Michael happy birthday but I was
just coming in for a high five and then
this dude just straight-up ddt'd me boom
into the floor and Vegas casino in like
literally like time and stopped like
everybody was just like boom the whole
place went so yeah the whole place was
I'm like old Filipino ladies stop
playing blackjack and like whoa
the dude from Harold and Kumar got body
slammed this is getting hot it's getting
hot we're only at number three son this
is a problem I'm asked your question
from getting Don truffle destroy the
world if given the nuclear codes so
here's my thing with Donald Trump but I
used to be a Celebrity Apprentice man
like I watched Donald Trump word all the
time I was like a Donald Trump fan
because I thought he was this sort of
interesting pop-culture figure he was so
entertaining on that show because this
is a show about him but he's only
appears for the first three minutes and
he like sets up the thing and then his
[ __ ] kids kind of carry it through
right and then he meets him at the
finish line at the boardroom right I
always thought it was interesting that
this guy who has his own show has even
out sourced his own hosting duties oh
yeah yeah like kind of yeah what's going
on with his presidential run where it's
like say what you will about Donald
Trump but he clearly just doesn't want
the job like even if you're voting for
him even if you're a fan of him like
it's clearly telling everybody that he
doesn't want the job doubling and
tripling down on all these niche things
but it's just like Celebrity Apprentice
it didn't even want that job he just
wanted the vanity project so I have this
theory what if we were all
tell him Donald you're president yeah
and he's not actually president but we
do a Truman Show thing mm-hmm where we
sort of all act like we're a part of
this play this is to save civilization
but we all act so when we see him
realize mr. president he's like oh yeah
I'm president but he's not actually
present we build him a fake White House
like he thinks that this whole thing is
real I think he would even like that I
think you would keep it yeah yeah where
do I sign yeah dude where's Joe liPuma I
need me and Joe the puna to stand next
to each other oh I'm Joe liPuma and
brown face and he's me and white face
like we're just a very there's various
shades of melanin between me and Joe
liPuma people on Twitter are like yo are
you Joe liPuma and I'm like a man I can
try I don't reduce no honestly give me
some of that zombie apocalypse chic and
I am Joe liPuma from the outside looking
in going to these political conventions
always seems like such a circus it
always seems so crazy yeah but I did
like the story that you did for The
Daily Show because it outlines an
interesting point
19 times at the on see yeah you get face
to face with people who you think you'll
have nothing in common with yes then you
start to have these conversations and
you realize that hey maybe we're not as
far apart as it looks on the news or
maybe we're not as far apart as it would
seem once we actually start talking did
you have that experience people came out
with the hats and the Cape capes and
like the all lives matter signs and it
was terrifying right to see like 15,000
people screaming yes lock her up
well that doesn't looks free it looked
crazy we approached some of them that
literally were like all lives matter and
then we presented the platforms for
black lives matter police accountability
body cameras all that's not probably
just not all they were like they were
like cool some reasonable to me yeah
they're like oh police officers from
those respective communities should
watch over those communities and yeah
sure
like they said yes to all of the policy
platforms it's like oh you didn't like
the shoe box that it came in like that
marketing and advertising for these
campaigns and for these people people
just fall for those holes and then yeah
and their self-interest all the time yes
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
so it's kinda tasty bug ads okay oh this
also great but come on mom when my mom
and dad was a little bit for this next
part some people might call it a crush
on hot ones maybe we're being lazy
maybe we're phoning it in but it always
is a great segment we just pull some
pictures from your Instagram some oldies
but goodies and we just need more
context and it's starting to hit this on
laptop please give me a second
so here's the things like these some of
these come in with like this left hook
uh-huh you'll see it coming and that's
one of them here's how I know that I
think you're part of the Illuminati you
you just you just had milk have you not
and I could have I could have put how
much more compared my milk to his mom
it's just doing this show weekly I'm not
I'm no superhero it's your reg like
during the week I'm don't tell me you're
eating this every day
me yeah every week Oh got to the Emmys
bad curry and that's one hell of an
Instagram picture man this was a crazy
situation I don't think I'll ever get
this to ever happen again in my life
what happened Game seven
courtside unbelievable Hodges a buddy of
mine knows Dan Gilbert he's like you
want to be my guess was like yeah I'll
be your guest
sign me up buting the beast I will be
your guest went courtside it was nuts
and like I'm gonna like I'm a true like
hoops fancy to go there I saw the block
I saw the LeBron block baseline I saw
Luke Waltons parents literally like just
their hearts just krump I saw it in real
time
that was that was LeBrons Muhammad Ali's
rumble in the jungle into the belly of
the beast
just get pounded rope-a-dope at the end
I'm the Great it's like we're all like
yeah you pretty much are one more was
this a weird time cuz it was like in
like oh oh man and you were like you had
this Cosby interview like right before
that whole avalanche began if you think
back on this time what do you think
about dudes it's trippy for you it was
Advil and so weird it's so crazy because
in the documentary stand up planet which
is which has now been like removed they
don't effort anymore because of that in
the documentary he was like you know
what's you know what's most important
about stand-up comedy stand-up comedy
about likability and I don't like you
and that is the best compliment to get
from a serial rapist hey man you gonna
you bother me that's the best thing that
could have ever happened that day I was
like I should quit comedy but now it's
amazing how life works you know what I
mean I'm like it all makes sense sure
you're an interesting guy in that you
know you do the political correspondent
stuff you do sketch comedy stuff if you
have one-man show stuff so I imagine
that there are a lot of people that
you've had in your life maybe you've
considered mentors we probably all have
a different opinion about who you should
be and what kind of performer you should
be best advice I ever received was
probably from Jon Stewart and John was
like moved towards her discomfort which
is maybe a metaphor as to why I'm here
no I really could agree with that as in
terms of subject matter like if there's
something that's making you
uncomfortable explore that like dig into
that now I'm getting like the starting
to bird in other places like my lips are
burning my gums are burning that's not
right no mistake I made sometimes is
like what they need food sometimes you
eat with your hands then you'll rub your
eyes I'll play your stuff like that pour
a little bit of yours into mine please
and go hard
thank you what do you remember about
Mike Tyson stand up when you shared the
bill with him was he making people out
money on stage
dude it was tragic I only say comedy and
tragedy are the two sides of the same
coin it's really tragic because he was
saying things that wasn't making anybody
laugh I'm not getting emotional cuz the
Mike Tyson stuff
it's the wing so when you got it you got
it this is ridiculous this is so mmm you
know one down Trump was like I want to
bring back worse than waterboarding this
is what he was talking he does come on
our show yeah you'll be like we should
bring this to Gitmo
there we go push and believe he was like
do you know what it's like to need money
and have to perform at people's birthday
parties because you have to pay rent I
was like man that is that's like that's
awful he's like a bull s'eye albeit I'll
be at kids birthday parties like these
16 year old white kids and those and
they'll be like can I take a picture
with you he's like I want to knock them
out but I can't and he's so humiliating
for me as a man so that was his material
at the houses material and I was like at
the laughs actors at the lab Factory at
the [ __ ] chuckle hut you just like
that crazy and people are just sitting
there in silence and I'm like this is a
true Greek tragedy
[Music]
I'm like thinking about my mother like
I'm trying to like think positive
thoughts you know your mom would be
proud that you made it this far not
everyone does including dj khaled he
doesn't know what this world is like
we're up in the clouds Mad Dog 357 used
to be our hottest sauce now it's our
second hottest sauce the Sun you holding
up can you make it through you are gonna
get like this your legs I kind of want
to like like I want to like play pickup
or something I want to hit the stage I
want to drop like 10 minutes cuz like
I'm feeling hyped that's the thing about
hot sauce yeah they say that you end up
kind of getting sort of a psychedelic
high off of it so I think you're really
feeling that yeah like I popped a Molly
I'm sweating yeah
[Music]
so one of your early jobs was with this
tech startup Ning right and I'm not sure
a lot of people know this but it's this
sort of blogging platform oh my god and
50 cent was one of the first this is
repeat honors this is full costuming did
he ever stop by the office or what do
you remember he never did but I used to
have to work really late at night I'm
just talking laughs that way I don't
feel like think about like sweating or
like think about eating I has to work I
used to work really late at night and I
had this sort of like esoteric like life
not esoteric like this like come to
Jesus realization moment where I was
like in a green room at a comedy club
doing a set before I was about to go
onstage and I had my computer it my
laptop in the green room and I'm like
this has got to stop
I'm an Indian guy doing tech support
right now this is wrong I do my set I
still have to work it's late at night
and um I was basically doing like
support on like something that was
happening wrong with like his network
and I accidentally shut the network off
like I shut down this is 50 I shut down
this is 50 dude and like at like 3
o'clock in the morning like I fall
asleep I got a call from like my manager
being like what's going on and a bunch
of people were like yo do not fess up to
this like don't take the don't take the
fall for this don't they won't know that
you shut it down
i fest up to the DA you made an enemy
out of 50 cent 50 cent made an enemy out
of you dude I pulled up the night of
like Messier I took the deal I said I
did the crime and I shouldn't have dude
I'm having an out-of-body experience
right now that's what we love like I
don't know this is real this is bad man
[Music]
so you're ready to do the last one and
you're a fancy no what's up it's Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage I like
to put a I'd you don't have what
everybody I'm doing but you have come
this far
son you have come this far it's up to
you you don't have to don't have to if
you don't want to is this
just compare this to this what we had so
fun well this by the numbers is the
worst one but and this might make you
feel a little bit better maybe a little
bit worse I think that this is the
hardest sauce to endure I think that
this one is the one that punches you in
the face the hardest this one by the
numbers the hottest but if you can
handle this you can handle this that's
what I think all right
please tell me this is all for something
like are we doing this for charity is
there some greater meeting no this is
all office for nothing this is I think
just a satisfies some sort of creative
vision dab dab dab dab damn damn damn
so through doing this show I know how
picky fans can be and there's even the
perception that we've changed something
about this show fans go nuts
I imagine that The Daily Show was like
that on steroids when the torch got
passed from John to Trevor what's been
the biggest challenge from the inside do
you ever feel the pressure of having to
be twice as good as you were for people
to think that you're performing at the
same level you know what it is Matt tell
me really what we do on the show it's
like political chopped we take the
ingredients of what we're given that day
we got to make sandcastles out of it
mm-hmm
that's all we're trying to do respect
the process Kobe Bryant Muse we're just
picking up marbles every day with our
toes building a sandcastle it's like
fine a little bit of Carly Fiorina we
got some Trump mega vetting that we're
doing on the show today we build a
sandcastle the water washed it away we
do it again do that like 200 plus times
a year that's what we're supposed to do
the Sun you made it through all the way
through cleared it honestly don't know
what I'm even saying are you proud of
yourself like you could ask me my social
security number on camera what so I give
it to you
five four I'm not gonna give it to you
all right man the floor is yours 30
seconds this camera that camera you like
to work this camera sometimes I've
noticed pick'em anyone that you want let
the world know what you have going on in
your life right now I'm on my one-man
show called homecoming king we're going
to 30-plus cities around the country we
talk about my life talk about
first-generation Brown experience and
what new brown America means to me
it's a great show it's like a brown John
Hughes movie we talk about love
racism forgiveness 70 minutes beautiful
theater visuals go to homecoming show
calm to get your tickets check us out in
a city near you
to pray for me